can i ask you about sort of
learning about bitcoin books and
resources you have
an amazing podcast that's not just about
bitcoin or cryptocurrency it's about
everything including life but you do
have a lot of really
amazing conversations about this whole
digital world but you oh obviously you
also have a newsletter
that's incredible on sub stack and
and um but do you have recommendations
maybe
it would be great if you could talk
about first of all your podcast and
the new newsletter but also other
resources that you recommend people
should check out
in order to learn about bitcoin yeah so
the podcasts and uh email are like the
two
most selfish things i do because the
podcast is a way for me to learn from
other people
so i get them to come on and tell me all
the things they're thinking about and i
get asked some questions
what's it called by the way uh just a
pomp podcast
and so in doing that um it really
is informative for me and i think that
my whole goal is just like if i'm
learning other people will be learning
and then the email i read it every
morning because it forces me
to collect my thoughts and actually
articulate them in somewhat of a
coherent way
and so it's just something that is like
a practice that i probably would do even
if no one read it
and then by being able to publish it uh
what does it do it elicits
you know both the good and bad responses
and so people will let me know if they
think i'm an idiot and they'll
usually not respond if they think that
it's something smart and so um those two
things are
uh really um educational for me and and
i think kind of forced me to uh to be
able to articulate a lot of ideas
but a lot of what i share or learn on
those things come from these other
resources so
i'm definitely subscribing people should
subscribe but what are
bitcoin resources books that you
recommend
i think you gotta start with bitcoin
standard uh that one to me feels like
uh it really lays out the picture nicely
um
there is uh bitcoin uh money you can't
[ __ ] with
i was written by our friend jason
williams uh as you can imagine it's
basically what it talks about uh there's
another book layered money
that's written by nick who uh who's done
a grant a great job
kind of laying it out um there's a book
uh called bitcoin in black america
written by a guy isaiah jackson and he
basically lays out the argument for why
uh the black community um can benefit in
a uh asymmetric way from something like
bitcoin
um and there's a whole bunch more i'm
gonna forget them all um there's the uh
i think it's called the cost of tomorrow
a guy
jeff booth jeff booth wrote it
and just if you get on twitter basically
you're going to see all these books
flying around
but i do have to say that uh from a
psychological concept or philosophical
concept the number one book that i've
ever read uh that aligns with bitcoin
ethos but doesn't say a word about
bitcoin
is a book called the dao of capital by
mark spitznagel
and so what he essentially does is he
just reiterates over and over and over
again
long-term thinking outliers disruption
all this stuff and so he's a guy who he
runs a fund
that essentially they just do uh tail
risk hedging
and so in you know march or february of
2020
they're up like 4 000 right
by the way they pretty much lose money
you know for eight nine years then that
happens and so
uh but they're still one of the best
performing funds if you look at it over
you know years and years and so it's
just this mindset of
uh everyone is so short-term focused and
so i think it's just a great reminder to
long-term thinking
uh and also i mean i've gotten quite a
bit of value just reading the papers
that's perhaps more like for technical
folks there's quite an
active research community and also going
back to the original white paper and
just uh original documents old school
old school still
uh what uh like what a few years ago
it's still really interesting
to think about to look at what people
were thinking about
because the the principles are carried
through
uh with uh other cryptocurrencies as
well like it's it's all
it's all there even in the early
documents so
it's kind of fascinating to see that
whole history from if you're more like
tech savvy
and like you said twitter is actually an
interesting place if you can look
past all the [ __ ] coin talk uh it's a
it's a fascinating place for news and
resources
you